called jung
and freud
which which team are you on i'm on young
freud is the better writer
but young has i think a model of the
psyche that is closer to where cognitive
science is heading
um he's more prescient so which aspect
of his model directly so freud has a
hydraulic model the psyche is like a
steam engine things are under pressure
and there's a fluid that's moving around
it's like like this is a record note of
this young has an organic model the
psyche is like a living being it's doing
all this opponent processing it's doing
all of this self-transcending and
growing
right and i think that's a much better
model of the psyche than
the sort of
uh steam engine model what do you think
about their view of the subconscious
mind
what do you think their view and your
own view
of what's going on there in the shadow
so all bad stuff some good stuff
um any stuff at all
well i mean both freud and young are
only talking about the psychodynamic
unconscious
which is only a small part of the
unconscious oh can you elaborate they're
talking about dynamics they're talking
about the the the
the aspects of the unconscious that have
to do
with your
your sort of ego development and and how
you are understanding and interpreting
yourself
yeah what else is there there's the
unconscious that allows you to turn the
noise coming out of my face hole into
ideas also there's the unconsciousness
memory access all that stuff which is
huge and powerful
and they didn't think about that they're
they're they're focused on the big
romantic stuff that you have to deal
with through psychotherapy that kind of
stuff which is relevant and important
i'm not dismissing i'm not saying it
doesn't exist but it's certainly not all
of the unconscious a lot of work that's
going on my colleague and deep friend
anderson todd is about can we take the
jungian stuff and the cognitive science
stuff and can we integrate it together
theoretically and so he's working on
that exactly that project
but nevertheless your census there is a
subconscious or at least an unconscious
i like the term unconscious and and
young continually reminded people that
the unconscious is unconscious that
we're not conscious of it and and that's
its fundamental property
yeah and then isn't the task
of therapy then to bring
to make the unconscious conscious
yeah to a degree
right but also
i mean yeah to bring
to to bring
to bring consciousness where there was
unconscious is part of jung's mythos but
it's also not the thought that that can
be completed part of the why you're
extending the reach of the conscious
mind is it so it can enter into more
proper
dialogical relationship
with the self-organizing system of the
unconscious mind
you